[Music]  i'd like to have a big third arm waving  high for the world to see  i'd like to have a second head always  staring back at me  i'd like to have a tiny nose the size of  a small clean  anything i'd take anything  but a uterus  i'd like to sail the seven seas be sick  for the rest of time  i'd like to quit this job i love and  become a times square mime  i'd like to live  in the mud  that would be divine  anything  i do anything  but have a uterus  [Music]  these people stormed the capital over a  rumor meanwhile we're losing our rights  and ain't doing [ __ ]  i'd like to have a puppy dog really calm  or really wild i'd like to have my own  hot sauce really spicy or really mild  but  i do not get to decide if i have a whole  ass child  anyone  i'd be anyone  except a person with a uterus  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign